this Dean is not not games and then you
get the other extreme Those Who blind
follow their like the Sufi he says that
if I wish he says I wish I could be your
slipper so you can wipe all your feet
all over me I don't want to be under
somebody I don't want to be somebody
slipper Allah did not create you and me
to be a a shoe Allah did not create you
and me to be a slipper for any man to
wipe his on
you or that if I was to melt his body
his flesh would be the Quran and his
bones will be the Sunnah what is this
the didn't go that far the they said yes
that the Quran is created but never said
that the flesh is Quran and and his his
bones is his Sunnah that if we melt the
man this is this is the Sufism that you
have
that's
it without a
doubt it is foolishness to to put on par
the statement of any
person even if it's scholar with the
statement ofi wasallam it's foolishness
because the statement of
is final there's nothing which is on par
with the statement
of everyone's statement is accepted or
rejected except the companion of this
grave so don't sit with these
individuals
as don't sit with
one put to trial because why
because he will he will leave with you
one of the two things you'll end up
being
upon either he trials you and you follow
him or he harms you before you leave him
that
is when he heard a person say I sit with
the people of Sunnah and I sit with the
people of as well I sit with
everybody
so the scholar the IM he
said this man he wants to bring together
truth and
falsehood and it's true what said and
commented on it and he said
I say this person does not know truth
and
falsehood nor disbelief from belief and
likewise and
likewise being upon
the is in your in defending
the the three categories
of knowing them in detail knowing the
knowing and affirming Allah's beautiful
names and attributes following the books
of the likes
of
book or the likes
of and you'll find in there many
narrations of the Sal and many quotes as
well from the in that book of the
volumes you'll find these books is where
salvation is you'll find the statements
of IM Ahmed you'll find the the advice
of sufyan
authority you'll find the statement the
advice of the of the past to each other
you'll find this the great imams in
defending the de of Allah subhana tala
but this this following the of s is it
not just in a it's in
methodology in methodology that we love
the Companions and we follow their path
and we don't speak out against them in
in in any ill manner that we respect
them we honor them we respect
the and we love them we don't follow
them in the era but we love them and we
keep their honor and also it is in
loving the people
of you see following the
as said how few areah if I know a person
of Sunnah is in the East or the west
then give my Salam to him cuz how few
areah so we have to love whether they're
in the East or the West the students and
also the the the the lay men amongst
them those who are upon the Sunnah we
have to love them it
is
in no matter how many times you talk it
or no matter how many times you studied
it no matter it is deficiency
that you don't side yourself
with but rather you're loner you keep
away from that's that's in your man in
your
methodology the great scholar is saying
give my Salam to them the prophet
Muhammad said are my brothers the sahab
said are we not your brothers said no
you are my companions my brothers how i'
love to see them at the End of Time
those who will hold on to their Dean
like they holding on to H cold my
brothers look The Messengers i' love to
see
them and all and and so if you're not
upon that then you
have because necessitates that you love
for Allah and you hate for Allah and you
give for Allah and you withhold for
Allah so loving for Allah's sake means
loving him loving his Dean and loving
the people of Sunnah not that
you not that you ah you leave them and
you don't be with them no we love people
of Sunnah we love the people of Sunnah
this is what we saw with our own
eyes from
the when we visited the he loved to have
the strangers of the people of Sunnah
who were strange from outside cities
that they will come and they will visit
I want to ask question and somebody came
between me and the sh he said he said
leave the sh leave the sh and the she
said no he's not from here he's you know
someone from outside let him let him
ask loving the people ofah and he gave
us big books of his of his tapes and his
da material his books and tapes such a
blessing such kindness such love
such likewise in in Mak and he's there
sitting with the students and he's
answering their questions and he's
painstakingly going through any issues
any problems that people have questions
that are in marriage questions that are
in uh whatever and he's thereare
clarifying the Sunnah to them and he's
patient upon
that 15 lessons or 13 lessons a week
that he used to give to the people of
Sunnah and I said to the this is hard on
you yeah he said what can I do these are
the people of Sunnah we have to help our
brothers of the Sunnah this is the love
that they have and every Thurs day after
which was a weekend at that time that
was a day that was a time his house was
open and he used to
have open
session his house open not only for Q&A
but also for those visitors that come
coffee
dates he's welcoming his his
guests how many time he accept accept
visitors to his house in his
80s and he's serving them while we're
all sitting around the the table he's
serving them and giving them making them
feel welcome and he would always say
that to the brothers who come from
England welcome
welcome welcome in face abdah this is
this is
Charity life is short and we have to
make the most of what we have left we
have to keep striving we have we have to
hold on to the Sunnah we have to take
the examples of
the of the narrations by Allah this is
where salvation is they're the ones you
will see them in like the inheritance of
the
prophets they are the inheritance of the
prophets the prophets don't leave behind
the they leave
behind so whoever gains it is gain a
great treasure so the should emanate in
one's actions the that one learns is not
something they learn in a book or a St
or certificate they get from a
university the certificate you may get
from a university an Islamic University
if you're not upon the Sunnah then it's
worthless it's worthless if you're not
upon the Sunnah and if you're and if you
are playing games
conniving and causing confusion and
doubts then there is deficiency in
youred deficiency in your manage
why because don't like that love the
people ofnah they love the people
of they're not people praise
themselves thinking that they're better
than others towering upon others that's
in because Allah
said don't go in the land full of Pride
Allah doesn't love every boastful Hy
person that walks on the Earth
don't go in the land full of Pride you
didn't reach the mountains in height nor
did you tread all of the
earth mentioned
from he
said he mentioned that there's a man
that a man come and he's speaking to me
about Hadith you see from the elders
from the scholars of Hadith but yet you
get some youth coming and he's speaking
to you about speaking to him
about and he says as if I've just heard
it for the first time and I've heard it
before he was even born I heard it
before he was even born you get people
like that all of a sudden I have done I
am this I have and I have been and I
studied and I have and I have and what
I've done and I have Subhan Allah be
careful of the eyes be careful of the
too many eyes I did this and I did that
and I'm this and I'm on top of the world
and I finish this book so many times and
I I I I and there's no one like me I'm
the main man and I'm the real student
and the true student no one like mean
Allah how can anyone reach me huh this
is this is deficiency in why because
Allah did not call you to this Allah
call you to the knowledge that benefits
is what is knowledge that humbles you
the knowledge that benefits is knowledge
that humbles you knowledge that makes
you return to Allah knowledge that makes
you fear
Allah those who fear Allah the most are
the as for somebody who just referring
to himself all the
time M he has harmed himself and that's
why always never feel that you're safe
never feel that you've made it never
feel that you've done it that you're the
person that everyone should return to
and everybody else ah you people in the
m just go and clean the the toilets and
go and clean the that attitude that is
that
is that
is Elders in the Masid they're the ones
who just go and clean the Masid and
you're the
man we are in need of Allah we are in
need of humility we are in need of we
are need of we are in need of lowering
our wings to our
brothers not Tower over the
Believers who are you for any statement
to be referred to you no that's
why
said the most stupid of people is he who
became misguided right at the end of his
life at the end of his journey even
though he came close to his above huh he
deviated that's why a person should
never feel self-sufficient how do you
know because of your self amazement
you're not going to be deviated that
is the deception of
a person who thinks that he's made it
none of us should feel like that and
none of us should feel arrogant rather
we should humble ourselves and ask Allah
for his forgiveness and ask Allah to
accept us and ask Allah subhana tala to
Pardon us
oh Allah don't make in our hearts hatred
for the Believers you see hatred for the
Believers
is is deficiency in have to love the
people of Sunnah we have to be with the
people ofnah
that is the reality of those who leave
this
dick is aair is all over the place may
Allah protect us from that deviation